nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
aujourd'hui Monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre de l'éducation nationale
dans notre mouvement humaniste et
démocrate l'éducation est une priorité
nous avons la chance avec Laurent
Croisier ici présent député du Doubs
d'animés ce que nous appelons un village
en fait un groupe de réflexion sur le
thème de l'éducation nous sommes
d'ailleurs tous les deux enseignants et
nous avons un point commun avec notre
président du Mouvement démocrate qui est
lui-même enseignant et qui a également
été ministre de l'éducation nationale
ce qui lui point commun avec notre
invité monsieur je vous donne la parole
monsieur le ministre de les questions
nationales pour nous présenter vos
perspectives
merci beaucoup ça marche merci beaucoup
bonjour à toutes et à tous et d'abord
merci pour l'invitation et merci d'avoir
réussi à trouver un moment pour que je
puisse intervenir avec vous merci à Maud
Gatel notamment qui a beaucoup aidé sur
l'organisation merci aux Jeunes
Démocrates leur président Auguste et
Pierre-Jean à qui j'adresse un salut
parce que c'est des vrais soutien sur
tout ce qu'on porte merci au
parlementaire à chacune et à chacun
d'entre vous alors effectivement on m'a
dit tu as 10 minutes pour tout dire sur
l'éducation nationale
pas évident donc ça risque de déborder
un peu déjà et surtout je reste après
pour le repas on pourra échanger très
directement et informalement c'est
difficile d'autant que je sais que c'est
un sujet sur lequel on est très attendu
ici au modem parce que vous l'avez dit
vous portez des valeurs humanistes vous
êtes toutes et tous ancrés partout sur
le territoire national et évidemment
qu'on est extrêmement attendu sur
l'école l'école de la République très
attendu aussi parce que je m'inscris
effectivement dans les pas de François
Bayrou je dois avouer que quand on est
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
qu'on cherche des repères dans l'action
de ministres qui nous ont précédés on en
revient assez vite à François Bayrou
quand on veut avancer sur l'égalité des
chances
sur l'exigence
alors que vous dire en quelques mots
vous dire d'abord que c'est une grande
fierté pour moi d'être ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
vous dire que si je devais résumer
l'ambition qui est la mienne résumé
l'action que je veux conduire pour
l'école de la République je veux
contribuer à bâtir une école heureuse et
exigeante et je mets volontairement les
deux mots l'un à côté de l'autre parce
que je considère que le bonheur à
l'école et immédiatement lié ou une
condition de très haut niveau d'exigence
comporte pour le niveau de nos élèves on
apprend pas bien quand on n'est pas
heureux à l'école et je pense que c'est
toujours très important de le réaffirmer
alors être heureux à l'école
c'est réaffirmer que l'école de la
République doit être un sanctuaire que
l'école de la République ce sont des
valeurs extrêmement fortes dont on ne
peut déroger et c'est vrai que au moment
de prendre mes fonctions j'ai tenu à
clarifier un certain nombre de points
notamment s'agissant de l'application de
la laïcité à l'école de la République
François avait aussi beaucoup agi sur ce
sujet là dès avant la loi de 2004 il me
semble important de rappeler que l'école
ça doit rester ce que j'en ai appelé
cette asile inviolable où les querelles
des hommes ne pénètrent pas l'école
c'est le lieu de l'émancipation on ne
peut pas laisser les querelles des
hommes entrer dans l'école on ne peut
pas laisser le prosélytisme s'installer
dans l'école c'est extrêmement important
de le rappeler et malheureusement on
voit qu'un certain nombre de formations
politiques ne portent plus et notamment
à gauche ne porte plus cet objectif-là
et ne porte plus cette valeur là au
quotidien c'est donc à nous de
l'apporter encore plus fort être heureux
à l'école je vais faire le lien avec un
sujet malheureusement et dramatiquement
d'actualité c'est lutter de manière
implacable contre le harcèlement
scolaire qui pourrit la vie de centaines
de milliers d'élèves chaque année des
centaines de milliers d'élèves qui parce
qu'ils sont malheureux à l'école parce
qu'ils vont à l'école la boule au ventre
et malheureusement désormais rentrent
chez eux la boule au ventre parce qu'ils
savent que le harcèlement va se
poursuivre sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
agir pour eux parce que ces élèves là
ils ne peuvent pas apprendre dans de
bonnes conditions quand on est harcelé
on a l'esprit totalement envahi par ça
il n'y a plus de place pour autre chose
lutter contre le harcèlement c'est aussi
lutter pour le niveau de nos élèves
parce que c'est lutté pour le bonheur de
nos élèves et donc pour leurs conditions
d'apprentissage c'est aussi important de
le réaffirmer on a présenté un plan avec
la première ministre un plan
interministériel qui me semble très
ambitieux et très complet et je veux
saluer toute l'action d'Erwan Balan qui
a mené ce combat depuis des années
et le plan qu'on a présenté reprend un
certain nombre des propositions qui
avaient été portées avec beaucoup de
courage depuis parfois quelques années
par
Erwan mais on y arrive
être heureux à l'école c'est réussir ce
très grand défi de l'inclusion scolaire
tous les élèves ont droit à l'école et
tous les élèves ont droit d'être heureux
à l'école et de ce point de vue là on a
un bilan qu'on doit mettre en avant on a
depuis 2017 créer un nouveau service
public celui de l'inclusion scolaire il
faut regarder tout le chemin qui a été
parcouru on a doublé le nombre d'élèves
en situation de handicap qui sont
accueillis dans nos établissements
scolaires on a recruté 50000
accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap aesh à qu'il faut rendre
hommage parce qu'il elle font un travail
absolument remarquable on a créé ce
nouveau
service public
pour autant est-ce qu'on est au bout du
sujet évidemment que non évidemment que
c'est encore dur pour beaucoup de
familles qui voient des notifications
MDPH qui arrivent très tardivement et
qui après la notification ont besoin
encore d'attendre avant de se voir
attribuer une aesh évidemment que c'est
difficile aussi pour des enseignants qui
parfois se sentent dépassé et moi je
vous le dis ici je suis préoccupé par
des tentatives d'instrumentalisation
politique de ces difficultés qu'on peut
constater sur le terrain l'extrême
droite allemande depuis quelques mois
maintenant a mis au cœur de son projet
politique le rejet de l'école inclusive
et on a vu en France au moment de la
dernière élection présidentielle qu'un
candidat d'extrême droite Eric Zemmour
avait placé ce sujet là aussi dans son
projet politique en rejetant l'école
inclusive il faut qu'on soit extrêmement
vigilant et notre responsabilité c'est
d'être vigilant à ce que les choses
avancent sur le terrain à ce que le
quotidien s'améliore pour les
enseignants pour les élèves pour les
familles d'élèves en situation de
handicap sinon cher certains chercher à
instrumentaliser ces difficultés pour
nous faire faire un grand retour en
arrière qui serait terrible pour l'école
de la République terrible pour nos
élèves terribles pour les familles et
terribles pour les enseignants soyons
vigilants sur ce sujet-là être heureux à
l'école c'est évidemment aussi avoir des
enseignants qui se sentent reconnus et
valorisés alors ça passe évidemment par
une reconnaissance financière là aussi
il y a probablement encore du travail à
mener mais enfin il faut quand même
mesurer ce qui est fait en cette rentrée
en 7 rentrée il y a une revalorisation
inédite et syndicats en conviennent
d'ailleurs demande plus chacun est dans
son rôle mais inédite depuis 20 ou 30
ans en cette rentrée chaque enseignant
gagne entre 125 et 250 euros net de plus
par mois qu'à la rentrée précédente on a
800 000 enseignants alors évidemment
c'est un effort budgétaire massif
important mais il était nécessaire et il
est juste pour nous enseignants mais la
reconnaissance évidemment elle ne
s'arrête pas là
et l'enjeu c'est aussi et là je crois
qu'on a une responsabilité même si ça
nous dépasse et on a une responsabilité
en tant que politique c'est la
reconnaissance sociale et sociétale
et c'est vrai quand vous échangez avec
des enseignants certains vous disent
parfois avoir le sentiment que dans
certaines familles on est passé du droit
à l'éducation au droit sur l'éducation
avec une remise en cause permanente et
incessante du travail des enseignants
avec aujourd'hui un enseignant sur deux
qui déclare dans les enquêtes s'auto
censurées dans leurs enseignements pour
beaucoup d'enjeux notamment les
questions de laïcité mais pas seulement
donc oui on a cette responsabilité aussi
de réaffirmer que la relation entre un
enseignant et un élève ça n'est pas une
relation d'égale à égale que la relation
entre un enseignant et une famille ça
n'est pas une relation d'égale à égale
et apporter en permanence notre soutien
et notre reconnaissance assez femme et
ses hommes qui s'engagent pour notre
nation à travers l'école de la
République
je parlais d'une école heureuse et
exigeante et je réaffirme que pour moi
les deux sujets sont liés l'exigence
elle est absolument nécessaire on doit
rehausser notre niveau d'exigence
on a grâce à l'action notamment de
Jean-Michel Blanquer des évaluations
aujourd'hui quasiment systématique on a
des évaluations de nos élèves début de
CP MCP CE1 CM1 depuis cette année 6e 4e
depuis cette année et seconde ça nous
donne une visibilité sur le niveau de
nos élèves et la réalité c'est qu'il y a
urgence à agir un élève de 4e de 2018
avait le niveau de 5e d'un élève de 1995
un an de perdu en 23 ans
parce qu'en 95 il y avait un bon
ministre absolument on peut le dire
je n'ai pas choisi la date par hasard
j'ai pas choisi la date par hasard on a
un élève sur trois qui rentre en 6e sans
savoir lire écrire et compter
convenablement
on a un élève sur 4 qui a moins de 4 sur
20 en mathématiques au brevet
on a un élève sur deux qui ne maîtrise
pas ou qui ne comprend pas les fractions
à l'entrée en seconde
peut pas accepter cette situation donc
il faut réaffirmer notre ambition
absolue de faire des savoirs
fondamentaux le cœur de notre action et
d'affirmer qu'on veut un choc des
savoirs fondamentaux dans notre pays
alors ça commence par quoi ça commence
évidemment par la formation des
enseignants la réalité c'est qu'on doit
revoir la manière dont on forme nos
enseignants et notamment revoir
l'organisation de la formation je vais
pas rentrer trop dans le concret on
pourra le faire au moment du déjeuner
avec les spécialistes ici mais la
réalité c'est qu'une succession de
réforme ou de choix qui se sont
enchaînés ces dernières années on
conduit à une situation on peut pas se
satisfaire de du niveau de formation
initial et ou par ailleurs le choix de
positionner le concours à bac + 5 à
entraîner un assèchement complet du
Vivier avec des élèves des étudiants qui
en deuxième année de master sont épuisés
entre le mémoire l'alternance le stage
etc et démissionne
donc on va revoir et c'est un chantier
qui a ouvert le président de la
République revoir profondément la
formation initiale de nos enseignants
et on assume de dire qu'il faut
peut-être inventer nos écoles normales
du 21e siècle assumer d'avoir un
recrutement après le bac
avec une formation extrêmement claire
sur les fondamentaux pendant trois ans
et ensuite un statut d'étudiant
stagiaire de fonctionnaires stagiaires
qui permet d'être rémunéré de rentrer
progressivement dans le métier c'est de
ça qu'on a besoin pour avoir des
enseignants en nombre et bien formé
relever le niveau d'exigence c'est aussi
assumer d'agir plus là où des élèves en
ont le plus besoin est-ce que la réalité
malheureusement c'est que notre système
reproduit encore trop les inégalités
sociales en inégalité scolaire il faut
réduire les inégalités à l'école c'est
notre ambition et là aussi on a un bilan
à mettre en avant
moi je rappelle l'action qui a été menée
notamment pour le dédoublement des
classes depuis 2017 il y a aujourd'hui
plus de 400 000 élèves qui chaque année
font leur entrée dans une classe
dédoublée on a des doubler le CP CE1 la
grande section de maternelle on est à
85% en cette rentrée on sera à 100% l'an
prochain et là les études le montrent
réduction des écarts en français et en
mathématiques de 15 à 40 % entre les
élèves qui sont en éducation prioritaire
et les autres élèves donc ça fonctionne
évidemment ça met du temps et ça mettra
du temps à se voir dans les fameux
classement qu'on nous met tout le temps
en avant le classement PISA qui va
sortir en décembre il ne tient pas
encore compte de cette action puisque
les élèves qui ont connu les premiers
des doublement en 2017 quand on les a
démarré je pense qu'ils ont aujourd'hui
12-13 ans le classement PISA c'est à 15
ans faudra attendre encore un peu avant
qu'on en mesure les effets mais la
réalité c'est qu'on voit déjà dans les
études qu'on fait avec l'Institut
statistique du ministère que ça produit
des effets et on va continuer on
généralise dans cette rentrée le
dispositif devoir fait pour accompagner
tous les élèves en 6e dans leurs devoirs
à l'école au collège le soir parce que
tout le monde n'a pas accès à une aide
aux devoirs à la maison on va poursuivre
cette action en faveur de la réduction
des inégalités scolaires relevez le
niveau d'exigence c'est assumer aussi de
revoir un certain nombre de programmes
et d'organisation la réalité c'est que
je d'un côté je vous ai rappelé le
constat sur le niveau à l'entrée en 6e
un élève sur trois qui ne maîtrise pas
les fondamentaux de l'autre on peut
avoir un autre constat qui est qu'on est
le pays de l'OCDE qui consacre à l'école
primaire le plus de temps au savoir
fondamentaux le plus de temps aux
mathématiques et aux Français
c'est encore été rappelé par le C2 dans
leur rapport il y a deux semaines
certains m'ont disent quand je voulais
lutter contre quand j'ai annoncé que je
voulais mettre en place des des temps
d'apprentissage du rapport à l'eau du
respect de l'autre de l'empathie de la
fraternité certains m'ont dit oui mais
il faut garder du temps pour les
français les mathématiques bien sûr mais
on est déjà ceux qui consacront le plus
de temps donc le sujet n'est pas le
temps qu'on y consacre le sujet c'est ce
qu'on y fait et là il faut assumer de
revoir un certain nombre de choses
d'assumer que maintenant avec le Conseil
scientifique de l'éducation nationale on
sait quelles sont les méthodes qui
fonctionnent et assumer qu'il faut que
ces méthodes se déploient le plus
largement possible au bénéfice de nos
élèves il faut assumer
d'agir au niveau du collège parce que la
réalité quand on regarde nos évaluations
c'est que le collège ne réduit pas
suffisamment les inégalités qu'on
constate en termes de niveau à l'entrée
et à la sortie et donc là aussi il faut
réinterroger un certain nombre de choses
je suis pas pour le retour aux classes
de niveau parce qu'un certain nombre
d'études qui ont été faites ont montré
qu'en plus d'être stigmatisant ça
n'était pas satisfaisant d'un point de
vue de réduction des écarts mais enfin
on peut imaginer on peut se poser la
question sur des matières fondamentales
français les mathématiques d'avoir des
groupes de niveau qui permettent à ceux
qui sont les plus en retard de remonter
et à ceux qui sont en avance de
continuer à progresser et que parfois
l'hétérogénéité trop forte dans une
classe ne produit pas le résultat
escompté et finit par tout niveler par
le bas moi je suis prêt à ouvrir tous
ces chantiers
on me fait signe que j'ai déjà été trop
long mais c'était important pour moi de
dresser ce paysage mais surtout de
réaffirmer qu'on doit tous et toutes et
je le dis ici en sachant que c'est le
cas ici défendre l'école de la
République j'entendais récemment dans la
presse une interrogation disait c'est
quoi le projet politique pour l'école
mais l'école c'est un projet politique
en soi en tout cas l'école telle que
nous on la conçoit
l'école publique gratuite laïque mixte
c'est un projet politique parce que
c'est pas le cas partout dans le monde
vous avez beaucoup de pays qui ne
partagent pas ce modèle
c'est un projet politique parce qu'on
voit qu'il comprit en France dans le
débat politique c'est encore un combat
on entend certains nous expliquer qu'il
faudrait revenir à l'école de la
Troisième République comme si c'était
parfait il y avait 1% de bacheliers à
l'époque c'était pas mieux
qu'aujourd'hui nous on assume que notre
projet politique c'est une école qui
forme les républicains les citoyens et
c'est une école qui démocratise le
savoir la question n'est pas de savoir
quel est le projet politique pour
l'école la question est de savoir si les
mots que traverse l'école notamment la
perte du niveau la question des droits
et devoirs question du bonheur à l'école
vont conduire notre pays à renoncer à ce
projet
moi je ne le crois pas je sais que vous
ne le croyez pas non plus alors ensemble
battons-nous pour une école de la
République fier heureuse et ambitieuse
merci à tous
oui bonjour à toutes et tous je voulais
vraiment remercier le ministre Gabriel
Attal pour sa présence ici parce que je
sais qu'il vient il prend du temps il
vient parler jusqu'à 15 minutes avec
nous et on voit à
l'immensité des sujets qui sont évoqués
l'immense chantier qui est devant nous
moi je dis souvent que l'école ou
l'éducation nationale traverse une crise
profonde et je la compare souvent à la
crise de l'hôpital et et je la compare
avec essian et il faut vraiment
s'atteler avec courage
et ambition à ce projet et je crois que
Gabriel Attal a au moins cette sincérité
là et de prendre les sujets de front
sans vouloir en cacher et mettre la
poussière en sous le tapis et je crois
que de ce point de vue on peut le
remercier en tout cas
sache que le modem et le groupe
parlementaire à l'Assemblée nationale
sera toujours aux côtés du ministre pour
aider dans la réflexion pour pousser ses
idées je voulais parce qu'on le temps
est vraiment très court je ne pouvais
pas conclure cet échange moi sans rendre
hommage à ceux dont Victor Hugo disait
qu'ils sont les jardiniers en
intelligence humaine je veux bien sûr
parler des enseignants les codes de la
République elle s'est construite autour
de valeurs et de principe fort dont les
professeurs ont toujours été les
gardiens on parle de transmission des
savoirs on parle de promesses
d'émancipation on parle de combat contre
lascination sociale on parle d'exigence
de bienveillance tous vocabulaire ce
sont les mots du MoDem et moi je suis
particulièrement fier qu'on puisse
porter ses valeurs au sein de notre
mouvement
Gabriel nous avait engagé la
revalorisation salariale je pense qu'il
faut il faudra la poursuivre en tout cas
nous demande à ce qu'elle soit
poursuivie mais vous l'avez dit c'est
plus qu'une revalorisation salariale qui
font engager c'est une revalorisation
sociale et morale et je crois que
l'ambition que nous portons modem c'est
de restaurer la place de l'enseignant
dans la société être restauré l'autorité
des enseignants et c'est finalement
impact sociétal qu'il faut reconstruire
autour de l'école autour de nos
enseignants et autour de nos valeurs
d'une certaine façon humaniste je crois
que nos professeurs méritent que nous
les soutenions et je voudrais qu'on leur
dise en tout cas aujourd'hui mais les
mois qui viennent c'est que on ne
reconstruira pas on ne réactivera pas
l'ascension sociale sans eux tout
simplement voilà donc je vais tout
simplement conclure en leur adressant et
vous serez j'imagine avec moi non plus
chaleureux applaudissements merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
je veux intervenir non
volontiers si on a le temps de prendre
des questions moi je suis très preneur
on m'avait dit qu'il y avait le déjeuner
mais
on peut faire les deux
François a dit donc c'est possible je
voulais je voulais on va pas en prendre
5 ans je voulais te mettre
peut-être en prendre en rafale
je veux bien si quelqu'un de mon équipe
a un stylo
Antoine un stylo
et un papier
bonjour
Je voulais vous peser une question par
rapport au débat précédent sur les
valeurs de la démocratie je pense que
ces valeurs on les acquiert aussi par le
biais de l'école comment est-ce qu'on
comment est-ce qu'on enseigne
actuellement ces valeurs à nos à nos
futurs à nos écoliers actuellement et
justement cette notion de démocratie et
d'institutions voilà merci
bonjour monsieur ministre je suis élu
dans le 93 vous avez parlé du sujet du
collège unique ou de classe unique
vous dire que vraiment on attend des
avancées de votre part là-dessus parce
que beaucoup de d'enfants fuient vers le
privé parce qu'ils ont peur du niveau et
donc peut-être qu'une des solutions et
j'aimerais que vous le développer c'est
de proposer des groupes de niveau pour
rassurer les enfants qui ne se
retrouveront pas dans des classes trop
difficiles merci
bonjour monsieur le ministre Hélène
polosec conseillère départementale à
Mayotte une petite question quand est-ce
que nous aurons le privilège de vous
avoir chez nous et juste une petite
remarque n'oublions pas l'ensemble de la
communauté pédagogique gestionnaire et
autres compris agents
[Applaudissements]
parcours aussi bonjour monsieur mélisse
bonjour à toutes et à tous je suis élue
dans le 78 et une expression qui a été
utilisée ce matin dans une autre dans un
autre débat m'a beaucoup marqué c'est le
BAC PROFESSIONNEL
est un bac déprime
moi je suis persuadée que redonner ou
donner parce qu'il n'a jamais eu de
l'aide de noblesse à la voix
professionnelle en France est
suffisamment tôt peut-être dès le
collège sera une façon de sauver
l'éducation nationale qu'en pensez-vous
après Mayotte si vous voulez venir dans
les dans les Yvelines vous serez bien
accueillis voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors merci pour
vos interventions
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire d'abord il
faut garantir qu'il ait lieu partout et
la réalité c'est que aujourd'hui
malheureusement c'est parfois un peu des
temps qui sont la variable d'ajustement
pour des enseignants qui veulent finir
leur programme alors je vais pas
évidemment le reprocher ça montre qu'on
a un travail à faire sur les programmes
d'une manière générale mais tous les
élèves n'ont pas accès à le MC première
chose deuxième chose il faut en
renforcer le volume horaire à un certain
nombre d'âge clé et troisième chose il
faut en revoir à la fois le contenu et
la manière dont on l'enseigne parce que
la réalité c'est qu'on a voulu y mettre
progressivement ces dernières années
beaucoup de choses à chaque fois qu'il y
a un problème dans la société on dit
finalement ça va se régler par l'école
et parler d'éducation civique non on
peut pas tout régler je pense qu'il faut
repartir de la finalité de
l'enseignement moral et civique formé
des républicains et à partir de là
construire le programme j'ai saisi le
Conseil supérieur des programmes sur le
sujet pour nous faire des propositions
et une manière de faire parce que je
pense qu'il s'agit pas simplement
d'enseigner il s'agit de faire adhérer
aux valeurs
j'ai pu voir moi sur un certain nombre
de décisions que j'ai eu à prendre
notamment en s'agissant de la laïcité de
la Baya dans des débats des discussions
que j'ai pu avoir avec des élèves j'ai
pu mesurer une une incompréhension
vis-à-vis de la laïcité et la loi de
2004 donc ça montre tout ce chemin qu'on
a encore à conduire donc moi je serais
très ouvert est-ce que sur ces temps-là
il y a aussi des temps on sort de
l'école on va avoir des expériences
d'engagement dans des associations
découvrir aussi ce que c'est que
l'engagement
je pense par ailleurs qu'il faut qu'on
soutienne toutes les initiatives qui
permettent à l'école de donner des rôles
qui permettent d'apprendre la
représentation et la démocratie et les
délégués de classe les échos délégués
les ambassadeurs de lutte contre le
harcèlement mais aussi les jeunes
journalistes de médias scolaires les
jeunes arbitres représentants du sport
scolaire les mentors il y a beaucoup
d'initiatives faut continuer à les
soutenir et à les développer sur la
deuxième question sur la fuite vers le
privé
oui quand je parlais tout à l'heure des
doutes et des inquiétudes la réalité
c'est que c'est ça aujourd'hui que je
sens traverser notre pays et ça rejoint
pour moi j'avais l'occasion de beaucoup
m'exprimer sur le sujet quand j'étais à
Bercy auparavant un constat plus large
sur le rapport des classes moyennes
françaises aujourd'hui au service public
qui se dégradent fortement elles ont
l'impression c'est dit souvent de payer
en travaillant pour financer un modèle
qui permet parfois à certains de ne pas
travailler
d'où le chantier qu'on a ouvert avec je
soutiens mes collègues qui avec beaucoup
de courage ouvert ce chantier de France
travail et de financer par leur travail
des services publics qui dont elles ont
le sentiment qu'il se dégrade et elles
ont parfois le sentiment de payer deux
fois elle paye avec leurs impôts pour
l'école de la République et en même
temps elle s'interroge à l'idée de
mettre leurs enfants dans le privé et
payer pour ça et pareil sur l'hôpital
donc pour moi répondre à ces enjeux là
redonner confiance dans l'école de la
République à l'ensemble des Français et
au classement moyenne c'est aussi
redonner confiance dans la République
tout court et dans l'impôt
et c'est vrai qu'on constate cette fuite
ou c'est volonté volonté de fuite donc
tout ce que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
sur l'exigence en matière de niveau je
le respecte des droits et devoirs dans
l'école sur l'école qui rend heureux et
l'école de l'émancipation pour moi ça
vise à répondre aussi à ses inquiétudes
parce que les familles qui vont dans le
privé elles y vont il faut regarder
pourquoi elles y vont elles y vont pas
pour le nombre d'élèves par classe il y
a plus d'élèves par classe en général
dans le privé que dans le public donc
c'est pas ça le débat
elles y vont pas a priori pour des
bâtiments qui seraient particulièrement
en meilleure état les bâtiments
scolaires publics sont plutôt en
meilleure état que les bâtiments privés
donc elles y vont pour moi pour ces
enjeux là la question du niveau je veux
être sûr que mon enfant pourra réussir
s'émanciper apprendre à l'école de la
République
pour les questions des droits et devoirs
je veux qu'on soit respecté que ça soit
pas la jungle qu'on lui apprenne aussi à
se comporter et puis la question de
l'émancipation je veux finalement qu'on
reconnaisse que chaque élève a un talent
qu'il a un talent qu'il distingue par
rapport aux autres et que le rôle de
l'école c'est de le révéler parler
l'éducation artistique et culturelle les
arts par le sport par la voie
professionnelle scolaire et du coup je
vais faire le lien immédiatement avec la
question suivante oui c'est vrai que la
voie professionnelle scolaire le lycée
pro a souffert pendant des années de
l'absence totale il faut que j'accélère
me dit Laurent de l'absence totale
devrait réforme et en cette rentrée il y
a une réforme profonde qui rentre en
vigueur alors évidemment chaque fois que
vous avez une réponse une réforme
structurelle il y a des inquiétudes il y
a des doutes on adaptera on avançant
mais enfin cette réforme à la mérite de
s'attaquer au sujet et c'est pas une
réforme d'économie on va dépenser un
milliard d'euros de plus par an pour le
lycée pro et la logique de cette réforme
c'est quoi c'est de dire que le lycée
pro ça doit être une voie d'excellence
pour nos jeunes
donc on doit assumer un de renforcer
l’apprentissage sur les fondamentaux que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure français
mathématiques on doit assumer d'ouvrir
sur des options qui aujourd'hui
n'existent pas mais qui permettent de
s'ouvrir au monde on doit assumer de
renforcer le temps de découverte des
milieux professionnels et de découverte
dans l'entreprise et enfin de rémunérer
ou d'indemniser les stagiaires de la
voie professionnelle qui contrairement
aux apprentis n'avaient aucune
gratification pour leur stage on leur
rapporte je peux vous dire que c'est un
coup puisque ça a été décidé quand
j'étais à Bercy au budget donc je l'ai
vu passer mais on l'assume c'est aussi
un enjeu de reconnaissance et puis c'est
d'assumer de regarder les filières qui
donnent des perspectives en matière
d'emploi et celles qui sont des filières
bouchées en matière de perspective on a
laissé quand même pendant des années des
jeunes aller dans des filières en
sachant très bien qu'à la fin il ne
trouverait pas d'emploi et qu'ils
auraient du mal à poursuivre leurs
études ensuite donc il faut assumer
d'avoir ce travail là sur les cartes de
formations même si il est pas évident
enfin
dernière question sur Mayotte alors je
viendrai évidemment à Mayotte dans les
prochains mois probablement au début
d'année 2024 évidemment on agit pour
Mayotte en ce moment avec la crise de
l'eau j'étais bloqué plusieurs millions
d'euros pour qu'il y ait des dispositifs
de potabilisation de l'eau dans nos
établissements scolaires on a recruté
une cinquantaine de personnels
supplémentaires pour ça je vais envoyer
un inspecteur général de l'Éducation
nationale pour renforcer les équipes du
rectorat et aider à ça c'est un Mayotte
aussi qu'on a développé des dispositifs
qui peuvent nous donner confiance pour
tout le pays notamment sur la lecture il
y a un très gros travail qui a été fait
il y a deux trois ans à Mayotte en
matière de lecture un travail qui a été
fait sur les manuels et sur le contenu
pédagogique et là la réduction de
l'écart en lecture a été de 40 points
grâce à ce travail là donc ça montre que
c'est possible donc oui il y a des défis
majeurs à Mayotte auquel on doit
répondre il y a aussi des signes
d'espoir et donc je me rendrai avec
beaucoup de plaisir à Mayotte comme dans
tous nos territoires ultramants merci à
tous
[Applaudissements]